that's why they did yes she did talk
about it we're talking about megyn kelly
there's a big Jane Fonda war which is
really awesome megyn kelly i mean this
seems like she's literally taking a page
out of the Barstow handbook where Jane
Fonda kind of just made this little like
shitty comment on The Today Show and
megyn kelly did like ten minutes with
clips about huh
what a schmuck Jane Fonda that is our
place yeah it's like something that
someone hits with a feather and you come
back with a sledgehammer right yeah but
you know what she's right this old bag
he's been talking about her plastic
surgery for years except nobody's ever
done it on ladies morning TV before
that's that's groundbreaking I love Jane
Fonda she's 80 she has hair like Tanner
Boyle had done so it's like a natural 80
year old woman right yeah it wouldn't be
weird if your grandmother look like that
if you're 80 and I'd [ __ ] you you've had
work done this year lady I suppose to
she J megyn kelly said she's 80 she
should date Dick LeBeau Dick LeBeau is
also 80 and like coach and football just
retired please take Lowell he's the
defensive coordinator for the Jags right
was the Steelers why he just retired as
just me he's gonna die within a years
old magic lotion for quality that's why
I should date Jane Towanda it's amazing
I'd [ __ ] Jane Fonda even if this poor
1937 she's 8 years old oh she's probably
like a New York [ __ ] too
she looks [ __ ] she I met her once she
was here she came in I said hello to her
quickly
a little dismissive in-county but then
again I had nothing to offer her but she
does look good for an old lady yeah well
I look like that at 80 I don't care what
you've done I'd be super dismissive and
super country wouldn't you be happy that
good and talked about yeah I'm
better-looking than you and I'm 80 right
deal with that how bad those [ __ ]
gets must look pretty yes must be a
horror show Jane Fonda is figured out
cuz it's all you got to choose one or
the other she's figured out how to look
good clothed right I mean at that age
you can't be a naked is off the table
she's like she's from the future
she wears things that cover up the neck
is the next one that they can't fix
yes you can lotion up your neck you can
do anything you want with your neck but
you cannot fix the next come on a shot I
know we're gonna be going all in on Jane
Fonda only here that's what they were
saying when Margot Robbie became Tonya
Harding they focused mostly on her neck
the makeup because they were saying that
her neck if you make your neck shitty
you can just make a person ugly oh shoot
I just saw that this weekend she was
still too pretty I think it's really
hard it's the neck is a [ __ ]
because you can't fix it they can't
tighten it or if you do who wasn't on
our show that somebody was talking about
one of those old actresses used to take
the other the the chicken wire and put
it under her neck and hold her [ __ ]
neck up I was talking to somebody about
that and that we would it would tighten
up the face and stop it from drooping I
don't remember I don't know sounds awful
yeah but that's how they would do it
like the 50s for her shots I mean she
looks good I'm just looking at she looks
good good bone structure how are outfit
on - yeah that's what you should start
wearing [ __ ] how are you guys doing here
how was your channel and all stuff yeah
everything's going well so far
you know the good thing about us is even
if it goes bad it's like people expect
it to go bad anyways right it's been
fairly flawless so far people seem to
like it so got a bunch of shows I think
we get like eight hours right now and
trying to add more butts been going well
so far
cuz you got to put out now you got to
put our daily content every day and it's
a lot of if there's a lot to go into it
I'm doing a whole [ __ ] channel not
just one show yeah
my father just launched the show with my
cousin Marie that's a big change
and Mike and my dad's name is Mike so we
call Mike in the Murdoch because okay
which basically the name is the only
reason we want to launch my dad and now
my cousin Marie um that that's been
interesting my dad actually just
yesterday on the radio and my dad didn't
even know he's on the radio but he
silently released that he had like a
Facebook page and he just set it up so
he could watch barstool me his son
basically do when we do like Facebook
live he released it by accident and
everyone started friending him now he
doesn't know how to use anything so he's
just getting notifications non-stop so
he's in like a world of hurt he
literally was like I thought it sound
like he was on the Titanic I mean he was
calling in a flat panic again not even
knowing was on the air just like help me
get me out of it somebody who has
notifications to their phone and said
why the [ __ ] do you need
gram notification check it later right
and that's my dad so my dad doesn't even
have like facebook on the app he doesn't
really know so that's actually been a
highlight I like kind of messing with
him so that's been a lot of fun and we
have my show Dan big cat as a show after
so we get the full day it's been going
what do you on four to six okay I'll
have to disagree tight it's a thousand
times oh so we were doing 12 to 2 we
switched it 4 to 6 opens old day oh yeah
whole day sleep late you [ __ ] do it
everyone after you guys have to get up
it's not that bad now I get up at 7 for
an 8 a.m. show and 5:30 why so early
well I got a drive-in and I get here
before cuz I live in Westchester so you
wanted you have to be traffic yeah so
you drive in everyday where do you park
I have a like parking a lot it's just
serious take care of that you get this
please jeez
yeah please like sorry tough I do a
monthly oh how much is that this could
be expensive four five five five five
hundred and ten a month no it's no no I
thought you have to go around 400 it's a
it's three something we're way more no
no no I did go around and find like the
cheapest lot I could find and sometimes
I have to wait cause like the parking
lot sucks because the you have to think
elevators you have to the cars have to
go in elevators go to the thing so they
can only do two cars at a time so more
mornings than not like I'm sitting there
just waiting on the street for the cars
to go in because they're sure at a time
two at a time two at a time so you wake
up at 5:30 and you get here by like I'm
gonna guess you get here by 15 yet yeah
it's early yeah I like I walk in be 10
of or or later I never get here before I
mean I used to do a show from 9:00 p.m.
to midnight and that was amazing yeah
that would be great yeah cuz I stay up
all night doesn't matter
I never like there was a it was for like
a year and change I never had a set an
alarm like I just never set an alarm
clock and it was amazing but now you
have a kid though then I got this - you
would have had it's different now kids
in the world right yeah children oh no
yeah I mean kids are the worst that was
like my schedule you don't want them no
no did your girlfriend want them or no
no so I'm separated we we never we
to the point we got separated right when
it was like kid time were you married
yes oh why don't you wanted you want
kids they're the worst
no balloon right it's just there's just
work everything about them stinks like
they wake you up in the morning going
like traveling with them basically
having any sort of fun in your life it
like seems like it stinks you've now
created this thing right you've created
maybe when you're like old and you need
someone but that like I'll just
hopefully get real richer just hire
somebody yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
I'm gonna need somebody to [ __ ] do you
know you created something no our school
is like a thing right you want to leave
that legacy this nobody's the legacy is
the parcels are killing you that's my
DNA that's your loan you don't you don't
want the Portnoy name to go like he's
gonna be the next guy to take part Oh
honestly and this sounds like I don't
know what this sounds like I if I had a
kid I'd want someone else to take care
of them till it's like 12 right and then
when they're 12 and they're not a pain
in the ass in terms of like diapers and
all that [ __ ] then I'll take them back
the thing about it though like and you
kind of [ __ ] up because you got a you
got you got to take your kid buy
yourself a lot right yeah but for me for
me having a kid has been like awesome
you know for me that but I have a
daughter you know but I'm you know old
too we'll see how that works out yeah I
mean I'm just a better person you also
need to find like the kids mom yeah I'm
assuming likes taking care of the kid
yeah she's yeah sure like you know yeah
my wife likes taking care of the kid too
so it's not like everything I do there's
just this like eleven month old being
like no I'm here I'm here I'm here it's
like I dread the waking up like all the
stuff is the crying oh that's yeah I
don't watch work but you know what
though but I think if it happened to you
just say you happen to you I think you
would be like you would deal with it
[Laughter]
you'll handle it
no you once you're there I think you
said like once you're there you're like
this you just make it work is what it is
you had a kid it's not it it's like you
make it work because there's no other
option but you're also not feeling like
oh I have to make this work you're like
this is actually kind of great yeah
let's start to man like your time is
like matter you know what I mean like
now it's like I would never like pass on
anything before my kid back I'll do
every show I'll do this with you that
but now like when you have a kid it's
like wait what meant what matters here
should I do this one this one listen and
it's been more effective so far a matter
like the white guys matter on the show
white guys matter because the theme
we're talking to Kevin yeah very trendy
for the time [ __ ] show that you're on
there they're mad that that white guys
have it so tough yeah I begin to so
Kevin's in some Twitter war with someone
the same last name as him yeah so no
it's bet it's by the way you know why
because Kevin Brennan I don't know you
know Kevin Brennan but yeah so he did
this he asked Chris to just be on a show
he's doing you know and Chris goes yeah
I'll be on the show he thought it's just
a comedy show and then after Chris has
already signed up for it then Kevin goes
yeah it's called
this is he just announces it it's called
the white guys matter show and Chris de
Stefano is on it
no I didn't very like Seinfeld when
they're going white power when the wrong
limo was that guy's name the main
character yeah I don't know a side note
I don't want complain I'm sure this
happens everybody yeah I ran out of
clothes so I took this sweatshirt out it
was like damp when I put it on now I'm
just soaked really damp why it hadn't
fully dried like you know when you put
on your yeah multi yeah no not yet but I
can get away with it'll surprise just a
damp rag right now how are you married
so date five married for six five seven
years the same person even or evening or
no no I mean I still we're like best
friends we actually it's been all very
civil about two years ago all right and
how old was she she so um 40 she's like
33 he looked great okay thank you yes so
that really is the phone you cut off
point I'm saying like if you oh yeah if
you wait past 33 and that yeah cuz she's
got to find somebody new and then do the
thing no it was the bus yeah and you're
at the point now if she found someone
else and you want her to be happy no man
I said I'm at a good age for kids now I
think I'm ready
no no I would disagree yeah I don't want
yeah no no I mean kids think [ __ ]
themselves yeah yeah they do I look
there's there's certainly an argument to
be made to not have kids absolutely I
could see it both ways but just having a
kid I'm like I now it's like [ __ ] if I
didn't have a kid my life would be but
that's because you know the kid this
because I know this like if you didn't
have your kid if I didn't have my kid
it'd be terrible but it's just
irresponsible parenting that makes me
hate kids like if I'm at a restaurant on
a plane and your kids crying I think you
should be like ejected I think that but
like you're a person who likes to win
right yeah like if you you would take
that philosophy into parenting you'd be
like [ __ ] all these but you can't do
anything right if a kid starts like I
just would never travel with my kid till
I was a thousand percent sure that yeah
well that's what I do that's I don't I
rarely take my daughter out into
restaurants when I know she's just gonna
be wild I'm just like we'll just I'll
order food and we'll chill here they do
act like little douchebag sometimes you
know it's the problems the parents that
don't take it I think you get out fright
like just walk your kid out I'm fine
with it like 92 right I'm finally it's
the ones that let him sit there it's
like you know this is like I'm trying
but your kid ruined my day
yeah I pick her to like [ __ ] idiot I
went to Salem Massachusetts and that's
like right yeah ten minutes from my
hometown I was doing some shows there
and then I um
and then I took her to I took my
daughter and my dad came with me and I
took them to like salem witch trial
music oh yeah yeah my daughter started
to cry in the middle of music - she'd be
terrified with it that was a [ __ ]
dumb matter meeting switches are real
yeah me and my dad was when me and my
dad showed up with our kid they were
like what the [ __ ] is going are you guys
like hiding from the police anyway and
then I was like well I was like oh you
know I thought she'd take a nap because
I wanted to see it and then she just
woke up started crying so it was no it's
not it's a selfish kid I think you that
you're not supposed to cry in these yeah
followed by a nice Freddy Krueger are
you too young to know what the [ __ ]
witch museum is when you're - no no you
know what witches are normal you - of
course you don't you don't you know
what's scary imagery is and that's just
like goblins and ghosts like even it -
you know what a witch is and you go like
hey I'm taking you to a museum where so
there's some have
those witches are real no matter what I
ever say can I take you to this Museum
if someone yells boo to a two-year-old
they're like whoa yeah cry pop balloons
by their heads in their sleeping but
like scary creepy things she's not you
know what my daughter honestly is scared
of football any time I have on football
she gets she's told you kids thing yeah
I watch the Super Bowl of Patriot kids
crying how did you feel okay you're
running bar stool right yeah an employee
comes to you decided to have kids but
you know there plenty of bars do in
place that kids and you're like I need
you to do it right up on this thing and
they're like oh I didn't watch the game
cuz my kids
he's she's scared of football so I
couldn't watch the game here's the door
bring the kid your Super Bowl party oh
no I mean I get a chance one day when is
a kid tolerable for you tell well I
basically said when they can play Little
League okay right that's yeah you send
them outside to get all that energy out
right they play with their friends and
it's like they're not like pooping
without control and stuff like that they
start to get snotty and shitty to the
hate your parent like when you're 12 13
you start to feel in Brandon you just
like your parents is up Dec you're like
[ __ ] you like you start to get nasty
that supposed to be when it gets bad
yeah yeah I wasn't like the terrible
twos though yeah that's my daughter's
two and a half pretty crazy I they're
starting to there's real evidence coming
in with your kids stink theory right now
yeah I don't want them ever yeah yeah I
thought for a while I might but then I'm
like no I thought yeah I've been dating
I have a kid with her and I'm like no I
mean and I know it's like nice to have
him in [ __ ] but I like the aspect of
being able to hey I want to pick up and
go to go away for the weekend I worry
about all this [ __ ] I can just go I can
spend a lot of time by myself though I
was watching something on a TED talk
today and they were saying that one of
the theatres the most important things
to living to 100 is a lot of social
interaction like it's like your
interactions with people the top two
things that will keep you alive a long
time that counter if you make up
characters and talk to them alone in
your part no it doesn't being nude alone
in your apartment to do it doesn't count
no and I realize I have interactions
here but not a lot when I'm at home by
myself a good amount of time
but that doesn't make you one day want
to have a child that's never you know
correction you could be a little buddy
there yeah right someone to scream at
and blame for my failures like you kid
takes care of you later or so social you
don't want to it's like if you're like
if you're like I'm kind of a selfish guy
like I like my lifestyle yeah
then you shouldn't be having a kid right
yeah I gots a selfish that's the right
truth
I appreciate though when people like you
know you say you know that I it's the
guys who like try to act like they're
not selfish that are like you know you
are no I know you have you haven't I
like I like that I respect them I
appreciate you respecting them yeah
what you need is my respect it might if
I know I'm too [ __ ] up to have a kid
and I don't have a kid that you could
move yeah I mean that's that's when
people end up being miserable is the
people who like get married because
they're supposed to know yeah kid
because they're supposed to move into a
house because they're supposed to and
they're just like following the corner
like townie mentality of just following
this thing and they're like I never
wanted any of this to be honest I get
stuck here to be honest with you
I'm a single dad now being a single dad
the last like a like nine months have
been like the best nine months of my
life because I'm with my daughter all
the time and then you know and I drop
her off and it's a time with her mom and
then any time her moms like hey can you
take the baby of course but like I get
like a break you know from right from
from being the individual attention
right man you get to go do your own
thing it's beautiful so how often do you
have I see my daughter I mean if I'm
home I'm see I see her every day like
today after this I'll go see her all day
sleep on my house and then tomorrow I'll
see her like four or five nights a week
sometimes it all depends on my schedule
but she's like you know I'm always if I
get free time I'm gonna go see her yeah
so you guys are split right oh yeah for
good for good okay oh yeah anyone else
no no she no not that I know of what
it'd be hard for your shows um you know
somebody yesterday sent me a DM from a
fan of this show he that he he thought
it was he he made a mistake with the
Instagram but what he sent me a picture
of my daughter's mom and was like bro
we're Eskimo brothers I just bang this
chick and I was like all [ __ ] like what
a social
he's doing it on purpose a message
before and he was like yeah I love you
on Jim Sam say oh boy and then he said
that felt and that was the first time
that ever happened was like oh [ __ ] I
thought I was over her but it's like a
little knife was her huh and then he put
hashtag Jersey Girls and I was like now
she's not from Jersey
what are you talking about yes she is
it's like no that's my kid's mom dude he
was like she doesn't have a kid and then
he had sent me the wrong pic she's like
this girl and it was a different girl
but the first text was a picture of my
daughter's mom but he just made a
mistake and I think he did it on purpose
and then realized oh that was a bad move
Chris didn't go for it you can make up
another girl he's [ __ ] with Chris
then you realize I'm not like Inspector
Gadget but how do you make that mistake
because I sent your no but then the girl
that he did send me the next girl that
he did send me we both did have sex with
we were Eskimo brothers on the woman
that's pretty cool but the one that
you're asking my brothers with you don't
care if he [ __ ] her I don't care if he
[ __ ] my daughter's mom no no the one
that he actually falling on